the key thing that we walked away with
with deep info max was that we don't
really care about estimating national
information we don't care about the
number that corresponds to how dependent
things are we just want a model that
understands whether or not there is more
or less mutual information so that we
could use that number as a learning
signal to train the encoder you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using dr. Devin
yelm is a senior researcher at the
Microsoft research lab in Montreal and
today he joins me to dive deep into his
research on deep info max a novel self
supervised learning approach to training
AI models and getting good
representations without human annotation
he also tells us how an interest in
neural networks first human and then
machine led to an inspiring career in
deep learning research that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
devyn yelm welcome to the podcast thank
you glad to be here so you're a senior
researcher who's deep into deep learning
at the MSR lab in Montreal so I've had
several of your colleagues on the show
over the last couple years and we've
talked about different flavors and
different approaches to machine learning
and learning machines but today I want
to hear your take on what you're all up
to there what's the big goal of your lab
and has it changed over the past couple
years at all or grown more nuanced given
new discoveries and advances in the
research well yeah so that is relatively
new it's only been under Microsoft or
MSR for like two or three years now and
the lab is also fairly diverse it
started from a background of like
machine reading comprehension and
language understanding trying to build
like tools based on language and
knowledge graphs and stuff like that for
people moving to Montreal and just
basically becoming part of the ecosystem
they're incorporating more deep learning
incorporating things like fairness and
fate its mission is very much still
focused on empowering people through
research and compute and stuff like that
right so how would you define sort of
the big audacious goal of the work
you're doing in Montreal so the team
that I'm part of we're kind of like the
deep learning camp I guess we're the
people who really focus on using these
very large deep neural networks and so
the core idea that were kind of like
really focused on is how do we use these
big things to help empower people give
them really interesting new useful tools
that improve their lives almost
everything that we're assuming here is
that we're going to be using deep
learning or deep neural networks to do
this because over the last decade or so
we've seen tremendous kind of like
explosion of utility on models that are
based off of deep learning right and we
anticipate that to continue to be the
case well let's talk more specifically
about what you're investigating
personally and why you think it's
important give us the virtual earth 3d
snapshot of the research interests you
have and what they bring to the broader
field of machine learning look at stub
and yelm up in the morning when you look
at when you're using like a large scale
model to produce something useful for
people in the world
you're kind of talking about the models
taking some data usually complex and
high dimensional that's coming from the
real world it's transforming it in some
way and then from that transformation
it's kind of producing utility so for
one example you can imagine like a
self-driving car it's exposed to a
camera video feed and then from that
camera video feed it builds an
understanding of kind of like all the
different objects that it sees in its
view for instance like different cars
different people and stuff like that and
then from there it like makes a decision
where to drive so that it successfully
navigates you down the road without any
catastrophic accidents so the
intermediate step in between that is
like what is the product of sort of like
the processing of that big network that
leads to the good performance so in the
case of self-driving car you need a
visual system that's able to identify
what all the objects are what they're
doing what their velocities might be and
so I can make good decisions on whether
or not I want to you know turn or go
straight or slam on the brakes or
something like that I'm really
interested in sort of like how do we
arrive to those good what we call
representations of the world from high
dimensional data
well let's rewind for a minute because
where you've been has influenced where
you are today you did a postdoc under
yoshua bengio
who's a bonafide turing award winner and
one of the godfathers of deep learning
and he also was one of the founders or
the founder of montreal institute of
learning algorithms or miele and I know
you're still collaborating with dr. Ben
geo today but talk a little bit about
what you were working on during your
postdoc days and how that work has
evolved and informed what you're working
on today yes I've always been like
extremely well influenced by yoshua and
also the general camp on which he kind
of is centered on which is the whole
deep learning camp
yoshua has always been sort of like
really strongly involved with Jenner
models and representation learning and
unsupervised learning so it was just
kind of like a natural fit for me to do
a postdoc over there so when I was there
I focused on Jenner of adversarial
networks also called Gans and this were
kind of like naturally led into
mutual information estimation because
there's a lot of parallels or kind of
similarities between how a generative
adversarial network learns to generate
data and how you might estimate mutual
information mm-hmm and then this
ultimately led into stuff having to do
with learning representations using
mutual creation and estimation all right
well I want to go back a little bit
because you mentioned a camp and if I
understand that it's like people getting
together and saying this is how I
believe this is my world view of deep
learning as opposed to another world
view of deep learning so can you kind of
differentiate what the difference is
there I mean ultimately everybody sort
of like interested in this general
problem space that I described initially
which was like how do you take complex
real-world data and do useful things
with it
how do you plan how do you reason stuff
like that but a key component of this is
how do you process or how do you
perceive the world up until sort of like
deep learning appeared the fields
weren't and having to render success on
how to process like very very large
dimensional data that was coming from
vision or natural language and so when
you look at the kind of like high-level
view of what it means to process complex
data and to do useful things on it
different people focus on different
parts of that so for instance there's a
whole field of people who basically
focus on features that are given from
very complex and old networks and just
figure out how to reason on top of those
but then there's also people who believe
that you know however we perceive the
world they should be packed into symbols
that resemble formal logic and we need
to be using these sorts of things if we
really want to be talking about solving
these really hard problems and so the
deep learning cap kind of sort of
defaults to the idea well we're just
going to throw the whole thing end to
end at the problem and train the whole
thing end to end and do back propagation
throwing as much data as possible at it
and you know it's worked really really
well and it continues to sort of be one
of the factors that drives us forward
well I think it's interesting because it
does affect you know your choice in
research on what direction you're going
and how you're going to
at the hill yeah and one of the
consequences of having to do things
end-to-end is it's extremely expensive
so it's actually becoming more and more
difficult back in the day people were
working with these static image data
sets that were small like 32 by 32
pixels and this was slowly expanded they
exploded to very very large data sets
people are working with video and with
that if you want to do things and to end
the compute cost goes up it becomes more
difficult to run like thousands of
trials the similar models to see which
ones work better and it becomes like a
thing that's harder for like smaller
researchers to do and more of a thing
that's done by the very biggest players
well we've been and I and by we I mean
you have been working on AI for more
than 50 years now and there's been some
amazing progress in the field especially
in deep learning when it comes to
performing easily definable and discrete
tasks but when it comes to performing
tasks in complex real-world situations
we are as you say still very far from
solving AI so in broad strokes I want
you to stick on a high level here what's
the big problem and what's holding
machines back IRL so I mean the way that
I see it one of the biggest challenges
that we're facing right now after sort
of like the surge of deep learning is
generalization so this is the ability
for a model given that it's been trained
in a certain way to perform well in a
different situation and this is really
important because it's either very
difficult to impossible to collect all
possible data that you would need that
would resemble sort of like the test
environment so for instance you can
imagine the self-driving car scenario
it's very expensive for me to try to
train a visual system under all possible
road conditions at all times a day at
all locations on earth and these models
they do have a tendency if you're not
careful to totally fail when you present
them with new combinations of data such
as that so if I only train in you know
Northern California and I transfer to
Quebec in the middle of winter there's
things about those systems that will
fail and then in addition to that I mean
if we want these things to work with
human
who are notoriously good at expressing
unique part to model behavior our models
have to be pretty good at generalizing
to that behavior to actually be useful
otherwise it will only be useful to like
a subset of the population and that's
not what we really strive for well one
of the thorniest long-standing
challenges to ml researchers is learning
good representations without annotation
and this is part of the expense problem
right it's the labeling data and so on
so what's wrong in your opinion with the
annotation model and the learning
algorithms behind it and what kinds of
learning algorithms do you think we need
to take us into a new ml future there's
a couple different things I suppose if
you're going to train a model under sort
of like the standard supervised setting
suppose I'm given like I said before
like self-driving car data and somebody
annotates like the position and the
class for every single object in the
visual scene and then I'm able to train
a model to do this end to end you know
it can resolve to a pretty good
representation that I might be able to
do some planning on but that annotation
alone is very difficult to do but on top
of that it's difficult to say whether or
not any particular annotation is useful
for a general task you know some scene
that's happening some video scene or
something like that you're trying to
describe what's going on how would a
human describe what's going on it might
only capture a fraction of what really
is going on and model trained in that
way might only be useful for certain
tasks and not for other
[Music]
when we're talking about learning good
representations that's sort of one of
the nuggets of what you're after right
so let's get specific and talk about how
you're taking a run at this good
representation Hill last year you
presented a paper at IC LR that outlines
an approach you call deep info max so
tell us about deep info max and start
kind of writ large what is it and what
are the learning principles on which
it's based
we'll get real specific and technical in
a second here but give us the big
picture sure sure so at the high level
it's a type of model that learns
representations in an unsupervised way
that is without labels that a human
needs to define ahead of time and it's
also I guess what's being called a self
supervised model and so this is a model
that kind of instead of tasks being
designed by a human in the sense that
the labels or targets that it's trying
to predict are coming from you know
something like the class cat or dog it
generates its own labels by basically
playing around with the statistics of
the data there's two kind of like core
themes behind deep info max so one is
you're given a bunch of data that has
some structure like there's patches I
can extract patches from images I can
present the model whole or parts of the
image and I can basically ask the model
can you tell whether or not these things
go together or not yeah so it's just
basically a two-way game just yes or no
does it go together so this is like one
part of it and then the other part is
like the actual function that you use to
train those things so there has to be
sort of like a number that the model
outputs that tells you how well it's
doing and this thing is the mutual
information estimation maximization
thing okay when you present a model say
two different sets of pairs and you ask
it to differentiate between these two
this effectively is forcing the model to
learn something about the mutual
information about the things that go
together because you're encouraging it
to understand the dependencies or the
relationships of the things that go
together so for instance if
give you a bunch of different pictures
of patches of the same cat you have to
understand a little bit of the structure
of a cat and so these things are
dependent or related in the sense that
they all eventually compose the same
thing a cat but if I present other
things and I just basically say you
should be able to tell that these things
go together as opposed to like say
patches that come from cats and dogs it
forces the model to learn that these
things are related let's unpack deep
info max technically on several levels
and start with a critical question that
I think you borrowed from Sesame Street
can you tell which thing is not like the
other
so you're addressing this with the
question does this pair belong together
how do you do that by both borrowing
from and diverging from the technical
approaches in the mutual information
neural estimator as you call it or mine
so mine at its core is meant to estimate
each one formation and so mutual
information is this quantity that
expresses how related to different
random variables are or how related to
different sets of random variables are
and so it's an extremely important
quantity because being able to tell how
related things are can help with all
sorts of things like prediction also so
there's sort of important downstream
tasks but it's also a very notoriously
difficult quantity to estimate so if you
have very high dimensional data that's
continuous say like images or language
there traditionally hasn't been any
straightforward way to estimate it
because you have to do this sort of like
infinite integral over distributions
that you don't necessarily know this is
where neural networks come in neural
networks and particular gans have this
ability to estimate log ratios of
probabilities without actually needing
to know what the structure of that
distribution is and what I mean by that
structure that distribution is like we
don't know if it's go cien or you know
Poisson distributed or whatever begins
they estimate these log ratios and then
they use them to train their generator
function
so if you look at the mutual information
it's just like a divergence it's a
difference like a difference between two
different distributions one is the Joint
Distribution between two variables and
one is the predicate marginals and so
the Joint Distribution is just basically
the probability that these two things Co
occur and then the product marginals is
their probabilities that they occur
independently of each other and so the
way the gans do this estimation is you
just draw samples from two different
distributions and you train a
discriminator as discriminator is just a
classifier so you just present samples
from one distribution because that
samples from the other distribution asks
does it belong to one distribution or
the other distribution yeah so this is
sort of like the technical thing so like
if for instance if I'm trying to train a
model that's able to distinguish between
you know cats and dogs I present it with
cats and I tell it hey this is label
zero I present it with dogs this is
label one and in the end of the day if
you train like a standard deep network
classifier it's learning to estimate the
log ratio of the probability of the cat
or probably a dog so mutual information
estimator what it essentially comes down
to is its training a classifier between
samples that go together and don't go
together
so deep info box is very much based on
our work on mutual information neural
estimator or mine what deep info max
basically does is it takes like a full
image and it presents it through deep
Bell Network and when it gets processed
through this deep neural network if you
look at different layers of this network
this is a convolutional neural network
so different locations of this
convolutional neural network have been
processed by different patches of the
image so you can think of these like
features at these different levels at
these different locations being part of
the input right so what deep info max
basically does is it says well all those
features basically go together so I'm
going to group them all together and
present them to a classifier and say
well
me that these go together classify it as
zero or one whatever you call together
and then take combinations of those
patch representations with images that
came from somewhere else put those
together and say these don't go together
okay and so that process is actually
very similar to what we did in mutual
information all estimation is the things
that go together these are really like
samples from the joint distribution the
things that don't go together well this
resembles something like samples from
the product of marginals
and so when you train a classifier to
distinguish between these two you're
training the model in a similar way that
you are in mind to interpret the
dependencies between all the things that
go together that make them go together
like why do they go together and that's
sort of like encoded into the idea about
the Joint Distribution so when you do
that you really are estimating something
like the mutual information but the key
thing that week walked away with with
deep info max was that we don't really
care about estimating mutual information
we don't care about the number that
corresponds to how dependent things are
we just want a model that understands
whether or not there's more or less
mutual information so that we could use
that number as a learning signal to
Train the encoder well let's talk a bit
more about some of the problems that
arise when you aim for as you call it
pure mutual information maximization
you've said in the past that's not
actually what we're aiming for here so
what do you do with the issues of noisy
information and what do you really want
to aim for here
I guess there's like two different ways
to answer that so one is that I mean
when we do this deep info mac style
learning on images while it does
resemble something like mutual
information maximization
there's a caveat in the sense that mine
is only an estimator it's sort of like a
lower bound to the mutual information
you can only learn the number of
dependencies that it's capable of based
on the capacity of the neural network
and the number of samples from the world
that it's received so the lower capacity
of the model the less stuff it'll be
able to learn the less samples it's
exposed to the less stuff it will be
able to learn but it has to learn
something so deep in
Max is based on this sort of like
structural thing where we patch things
in different ways this kind of biases
the model to learn things that are
expressible structurally so for instance
because I'm effectively doing a
comparison kind of game between
different patches of the same image it
needs to understand why those patches
are related and maybe doesn't need to
understand something more nuanced like
the texture of one of the patches
compared to the other and the reason why
it doesn't need to understand that is
because it's maybe not learn about it's
a much harder problem than just
understanding whether or not like the
shape goes together or the general color
goes together or something like that so
the model will focus on those things
that are easy to pick up I have a lot of
times how we design these tests this way
of breaking up the data in a particular
way when we apply it to mutual
information neural estimation style
learning or deepen from acts matters
more than the actual objective that we
use so is there anything different or
anything sort of noteworthy about any of
the technical aspects of deep info max
that sort of say hey stand up and take
notice this is a new approach to solving
some of these problems so the main
nuance thing about the deep info max
model was that so as I mentioned before
we were taking these local
representations these features that
corresponded to a patch of the input and
it's important in deep info max if you
do things that way that those features
actually correspond to a patch what's
interesting about a lot of the
convolutional models that are used in
the while like the very popular ones
like ResNet while they have a spatial
extent as you progress through the
network very very quickly those
locations cover the whole input so even
though it has a spatial extent there are
locations that are spatial in the neural
network but if you back project and look
at the stuff that is processed it's
actually processing the whole input so
that's not actually a different view of
the input anymore it's good and bad in
the sense that it's nice that at some
point the architecture
mixing everything a can from the input
try to infer whether or not something
belongs to a class in the case of
supervised learning but in the case of
self supervised learning if you want to
really leverage these locations from the
natural architecture then you need to be
a little bit more careful about how you
apply architectures so if you have these
architectures that quickly expand over
the full receptive field of the input
then you run into trouble and so deep in
from X is kind of particular in that it
really tried to leverage the internal
structure of the model over just say
like pure messing with the input data
and then design losses on top of it
[Music]
at this point in the podcast Devin I
always ask my guests what could possibly
go wrong
so I'll ask you to and I do this because
I want to address some of the elephants
in the room where you know this is a
powerful technology is there anything
about your work that keeps you up at
night metaphorically and if so how are
you addressing it I think we all have to
kind of like think about this whether or
not our work is like more directly
related to things like fairness and
privacy and and nefarious agents and if
we don't so some people particularly
like the a-team focus more on like so
that the reasoning aspects of our models
like how do they take data presented to
them and produce results that are fair
or retain privacy and stuff like that
but kind of like the general trend that
we're seeing is that we're using for our
reasoning we're using more and more deep
models that produce features that people
use to do that reasoning on top of and
so I'm very much interested in how the
quality of those features of that model
impact these I don't like to call moral
metrics so for instance is it possible
that my model it was presented with a
face of a person also encodes their
identity perfectly or something like
that that my features either do or don't
make it easy for someone to it for where
those features came from and their
identities they might want to keep
hidden so yeah I mean like in particular
when you're talking about like the
mutual information stuff like we're
working really hard on maximizing each
one formation all over the place so
we're just trying to capture as much
information about the data as possible
but you could also imagine using the
same techniques to minimize mutual
information so you just put the sign on
some of the objective functions and say
okay there's these properties that I
really don't want in this representation
whatever you do whatever this
representation looks like minimize it
you use the exact same object
function to try to do the exact same
thing it's a little bit trickier because
you're dealing with this min max but you
can imagine doing stuff like that so
it's it's like another sub part of that
whole question about what a good
representation is is sometimes you don't
really want all the underlying things in
that representations you maybe want to
actually hide things yeah yeah yeah I
don't want to drill in just a little bit
on how you can control at the outset
keeping a lid on the things that you
could see going wrong with machines that
act in the world like humans do and pass
the Turing test on a grand scale so when
we talk about whether or not a
representation is good or not or useful
which I guess is like sort of like the
core of what I'm focused on it's
important that among the collection of
things that we use to evaluate our
models we keep in mind metrics that
evaluate things like fairness and
privacy so one thing that we're seeing
as we progress in representation
learning is that it's not just like one
metric that really matters as far as
like whether or not the representation
is gonna be good for deployment on some
complicated downstream tasks it's not
going to be just classification there's
like a suite of things that we have to
evaluate models on and the suite of
things kind of like provides a better
story like a fine-grained story as far
as like whether or not this
representation truly is going to be
useful and one of those dimensions of
usefulness is things like privacy and
fairness mm-hmm speaking of stories tell
us about yourself Devon and your path to
machine learning research at MSR and
house the ML game better since you
joined the team I mean I guess I've
always been pretty interested in
representation learning like
understanding representations of the
world like deriving them so I started in
physics which is about learning about
representations of the world which have
to deal with like dynamics and all sorts
of quantities physical quantities and
and then I got interested in languages
because I was interested in how people
represent the
world through their language through
words and their relationships and stuff
like that and so I went from physics to
linguistics and did a stint there so I
quickly realized that like at least
where I was at they didn't have the
tools necessary to really solve the
types of problems that I was interested
in which was like understanding from
language how humans represent the world
so I started getting really interested
in using you know computers to help
solve these problems like models and
stuff like that so I got involved with
some people over at the CES Department
and then joined the ph.d program in
computer science at University of New
Mexico probably like one of the stronger
sort of like groups that were focusing
on like modeling complex data and
learning representations were on the
neuroimaging side so there was like a
big Research Institute called the mind
research network so I talked to Vince
Calhoun who's still chief officer over
there and I said hey I'm interested in
these deep neural networks I think they
might be useful for neuroscience stuff
they were looking at like sort of like
brain imaging data like fMRI EEG and
some other related data sets and modes
they said oh okay well here's some
public data we have available try your
model on it and see how it works and I
did it and I produced something
interesting and okay well I'll take you
on as a grad student so I lived over
there for a couple years and I was kind
of like the black sheep who was using
the deep neural networks while everybody
else was using these more linear models
like ICA and PCA and stuff like that so
me and my sort of like unofficial
adviser Sergey please we're kind of like
the deep learning nerds and we put out
some nice papers that use deep learning
and showed that it work with fMRI data
and but through that whole process
because my research network was such a
good research institution with good
connections and grant money and stuff
like that they were able to connect our
small group to a bunch of really big
names and deeply
like Russell cotton often Canyon Cho
russ was at the time like a professor at
University of Toronto he's since moved
on to CMU and Canyon Cho was a postdoc
at the time with Yosh wanna you know at
this entire time I'm like pushing on the
whole representation learning stuff but
in the context of neuroimaging learning
how to use new models even my stuff with
general models it was all about learning
good representations because you can use
the intermediate states for general
models as representations as well and
just through those connections I was
able to get like more deep learning
papers into europes and through that
connection I was able to like reach out
to yoshua at the end of my PhD and was
able to connect up with them there and
so you were at Mila for a while montreal
institute of learning algorithms yeah
I'm still an adjunct professor there
okay I still go supervise students and
help them with the research what's one
thing we don't know about you Devan
something interesting that may have
impacted your career sort of personal
maybe it's a side quest or a personality
trait or something interesting just sort
of give us context about who you are a
little deeper in well I played bass you
know more or less professionally for
three years in grad school I mean a band
like yeah like I'd have kids like three
sometimes four days a week yeah playing
salsa are you kidding yeah not so yeah
we would play everywhere from like
casinos to like dances to everything
like that I mean I played music my
entire life but I was pretty ambitious
about being very very good and so that
group was pretty cool because there were
super high skills also musicians from
like all over the world one person was
from like a touring group in Cuba and
there was another guy who joined her
group who was on some Grammy oblems and
so so I got to do that for a little
while it it was it was really good so
like I was working as a musician
during my PG do you still play I don't
play bass anymore because I got tired of
spending all my Fridays and Saturdays
playing the same music all the time and
not being able to like sit and like
enjoy watching someone else play right
now I'm learning how to play the
mandolin because it's easier to play by
yourself let's get some parting thoughts
and shots in as we close I want to give
you the chance to think ahead and dream
about the future let's say you're wildly
successful Devin what will the world
look like at the end of your career what
will you have accomplished in your field
and what will we be able to do and we
hadn't been able to do before I can
imagine all sorts of like things that we
could do with models that we can't do
today like for instance like present and
a model to a brand new environment it's
able to navigate and explore this
environment on its own with very little
help from human experimenters and learn
everything it needs to learn to do
useful stuff I firmly believe that it's
like important that our ultimate goal
for for all of this AI effort is to
arrive to models and algorithms and
agents that are useful to human beings
in the real world so that they can do
things that they couldn't do before more
easily sort of like to empower the more
general population on top of that if I
was wildly successful is continuing and
ongoing exciting community of people
working on really difficult problems
because they're passionate about it
everybody has sort of like their own
ideas for I was like what would be
useful or good for people and as long as
I'm part of that someone who gets to
interact with that community and and
help build and shape those things I
think that's the best possible thing
that I can hope for and so I'm just
hoping that like I can be part of that
committee and it continues to thrive
Devin young thank you for joining us
today has been really fun thank you
[Applause]
to learn more about dr. Danielle and the
very latest in deep learning research
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]